if you are a longtime watcher of this
channel you know i am a fan of
everything elon however i haven't talked
much about his boring company in a while
but now i finally have some big news to
share with you guys so stick around as i
take you through this big update and
what it might mean for subterranean
transport going forward what's the
boring company if you're unfamiliar with
the boring company you'd be forgiven for
it but unlike tesla and spacex not a lot
of people know about this venture of
elon's anyways as the name suggests the
boring company does precisely that and
no it doesn't bore people but rather it
bores through the earth making gigantic
tunnels for transportation you see elon
believes that tunneling is the solution
to the traffic log jams that most cities
face he believes that the next evolution
of terrestrial transportation will occur
underground through massive subterranean
networks of tunnels zigzagging under our
cityscapes and the boring company has
been working towards that goal since
2016 to achieve traffic-free roads in
busy areas of cities so that people can
save time fuel and money so what is this
big update that the boring company
announced recently in late april the
company announced that it had raised
another
675 million dollars in a series c
funding round which now takes its
valuation to a staggering
5.675 billion dollars but has the boring
company achieved anything to reach such
a high valuation do they even have a
working service or a proof of concept
that can be rolled out to the public to
know the answer to these questions stick
around until the end it's going to be
quite a joyride what has the boring
company achieved so far the boring
company started out with some lofty
ambitions as you would expect no doubt
from a company owned by elon but in its
5 odd years of operation the
expectations have dampened a bit don't
get me wrong even though the company is
still in its early days it has made some
significant progress but the initial
promises are taking longer than expected
to materialize the initial buzz around
the company was because of its goal to
develop the infrastructure for a
hyperloop system that can transport
people at a mind-boggling speed of 600
plus miles per hour in autonomous
electric pods although the company has
conducted various tests hyperloop still
remains a concept and a working
prototype is still years away so the
company has had to adjust its goals
towards more viable projects it has now
pivoted from hyperloops to self-driven
teslas in tunnels the only project it's
completed so far is the las vegas
convention center loop or lvcc loop it
is a three-station transportation system
consisting of 1.7 miles of tunnel built
to transport people between the
different convention halls the loop
became operational in april of 2021 and
it was the company's first proof of
concept with tesla's driving through
tunnels for now the loop is a service
provided by human-driven teslas
traveling at most 40 miles per hour
although it falls way short of the
company's earlier visions of
self-driving cars traveling as fast as
150 miles per hour moving to and from
surface streets and automated elevators
it still improves on the previous
transportation picture by some order of
magnitude the loop connects the lvcc's
west hall with the existing campus and
reduces a 45-minute cross-campus journey
time to approximately two minutes during
busy convention times it can transport
anywhere between 15 000 to 25 000
passengers per day the project took a
year to complete at the cost of
approximately 47 million dollars so
although the project is far away from
its final vision of fully self-driven
teslas ferrying people at high speeds it
was good enough for the las vegas
authorities to not only approve an
extension project to the nearby worlds
resort but on october 20th 2021 the
clark county commissioners unanimously
approved a new project called the vegas
loop a 29-mile tunnel network connecting
51 stations across the las vegas strip
this has been a major scoop for elon and
the boring company as it is the first
sign of support from a major city to
commit to its underground transportation
concept after this municipalities like
los angeles chicago and washington dc
have all started to show an active
interest in similar concepts for their
cities this has finally opened the
company's floodgates prompting renewed
interest from investors and leading to
one of this video's main focuses a fresh
round of funding what's next for the
boring company now that the company has
raised a fresh round of funding it is
looking to accelerate its tunneling
plans it is also working on developing
new technologies to reduce the cost and
time of building these tunnels according
to their recent statements most of the
new funding will be used towards its
vegas loop project still a significant
portion of the budget will also go into
developing their next generation boring
machine called the proofrock for its
first research tunnel project the boring
company basically bought a secondhand
tunnel boring machine called the godot
and modified it for their purposes after
completing this initial mile-long tunnel
the company again purchased and modified
a second machine this second generation
boring machine was called the line storm
and would serve as the company's
workhorse for the lvcc loop but all of
this tinkering of secondhand boring
machines was leading up towards
something more significant the team back
at base was working hard to develop a
unique all-electric high-powered tunnel
boring machine that could mine 10 times
faster than any existing tunneling
machine the proofrock according to elon
existing tunnel boring companies spend
only about 10 minutes per hour actually
drilling the other 50 minutes are spent
installing the reinforcements removing
all the dirt and deploying all the
logistics behind the mining process this
makes existing tunneling technology
extraordinarily inefficient and costly
with proofrock the boring company is
working to increase the overall
efficiency of tunneling by a factor of
three they have modified the cutter
design and added an automated segment
erection system by engineering a system
that automatically takes care of all the
reinforcement and dirt removal the
company predicts a 15 times improvement
in the speed of boring versus the next
best technology out there proofrock 1
first broke ground in early 2020 with
the company commemorating that moment
with a tweet proofrock is alive since
then the new boring machine has been
hard at work expanding the lvcc loop and
now it will be used exclusively for the
29 miles of the las vegas loop as it
drills this new network of tunnels the
company will continuously improve the
design and release new versions of the
proofrock along the way what about the
hyperloop although the company is
focused on optimizing its tesla driven
tunnel transportation concept it hasn't
forgotten about the ultimate goal the
hyperloop right after securing this new
round of funding in late april the
company tweeted hyperloop testing at
full scale begins later this year elon
also chimed in by tweeting that the
boring company will attempt to build a
working hyperloop in the coming years
although he was strangely non-committal
about a time frame when probed further
by twitter users i believe despite the
boring company attempting to drum up
interest in the hyperloop once again the
project is far from being realized that
doesn't mean the company is not working
on it it most definitely has a team
researching it in earnest still for now
i believe the company will be laser
focused on achieving its lesser dream of
having autonomous tesla zigzagging
underground at speeds of 150 miles an
hour first after all it needs a fully
operational public mode of transport
that generates revenue to justify its
enormous valuation to its investors if
you think about it the sooner the
company completes the las vegas loop and
makes it operational the better it will
be for its reputation and credibility as
there are many people out there who are
critically looking at the company for
boasting such an enormous valuation
without having developed a single
revenue generating service and in the
future if the company can successfully
pair fast autonomous teslas with quick
tunnelling technology then many more
city councils across the us will be
interested in allowing them to tunnel
their streets and have super quick
point-to-point transportation so because
of all the reasons mentioned above i
believe the hyperloop will take a bit of
a back seat for now but who knows it is
a company backed by elon after all and
we all know how quickly they can bring
about technological breakthroughs so
maybe we will get to see a working
hyperloop before this decade runs out
what do you think do you agree with my
prediction let me know in the comment
section below if you enjoyed this update
on the boring company give this video a
like and subscribe to the channel see
you in the next one